you've never tried salt licorice
beforehand sir i'm very excited to see
this
holy sh
sorry welcome to oh my god
you people are crazy this is how we
treat ourselves that actually burned my
tongue
i can't believe you gave that to
children and that's insane
[Music]
hello my name is alexander skarsgard i
am
and i am anya taylor joy and this is
snack wars for lad bible
let's do it who do you represent today
uk
sweden
[Music]
oh
yes this is a sausage roll sausage roll
wins immediately this is a greg's
sausage roll this is the is it yeah
i love this vegan meatballs
all right i had you
hate me right now
this man eats meat like i like i like
vegan stuff i have this for breakfast
like nearly every day on emma
mm-hmm
i love this
it's not exactly an explosion of flavor
in my mouth but
i'm insulted greg's is like
a national treasure
vegan meatballs
[Music]
this is um unique
i'm gonna i'm gonna go for greg's thanks
yeah i'm with you greg
oh
all right you and the drawing this is uh
salt licorice uh candy licorice and
these are like greasy gummies
it's also quite uh
sentimental because
this is like from my
from my childhood
it's a very it's very it's
salt licorice
is is very very popular
because we're
weird
i'm curious to see you try it you've
never tried salt licorice beforehand in
there so i'm very excited to see this
holy sh
sorry welcome
you people are crazy this is how we
treat ourselves that actually burned my
tongue
it tastes like a mouthful of seawater it
tastes like you'd made a mistake you
know what i mean when you fell into the
water
i can't believe you give that to
children
all righty go for it what would you like
go for the there's one okay
that's delicious
it's quite good
all the way this for um
this is unique i don't
um like
candy in general but i if i'm
if i'm going to have some candy i think
it's going to be
you know
of course salt licorice in in any form
is it still in your teeth yeah yeah
is it going to spit out i'm not gonna
spit but i'm definitely gonna use my
claw
thank you
that is insanity one two three let's go
oh brilliant oh my goodness okay yeah
well these are mine are these not yours
no yeah this is a pickled cucumber uh
salt
in swedish it's delicious apparently i'm
pickled onions
well these bad boys are massive
i don't actually know how i eat this
let me let me help you oh god i'll get
you one i'm real excited i can't even
get it
it's a sheep eye
thank you so much thank you my love all
right
[Music]
wow
oh it keeps going
wow
it's actually quite nice okay i'm gonna
go for this one
it's quite good isn't it
it reminds me of like hot dogs well this
was really really nice but i'm gonna
have to go with the self cooker i'm to
have to give it to sweden also
that onion just keeps going from two to
three here we go nope
i think these are love hearts we used to
give them to each other at school they
have like little messages on them what
is that no idea it looks radioactive
yeah but look at these ones did you have
to put this in my mouth this one says
cuddle me this one says i will kill you
okay so they've got different love
hearts
oh you went for it that smells really
strong okay
what does it taste like nope
you want the spit bucket yeah so buffy
for ally
can i nibble
it's
dug
well
i haven't even tasted this but if this
tastes like fermented shark i would go
for it because this is cute do you want
um a sad crying face an ice a con
or do you like
it's love it's love
i'm gonna go for cuddle me
say fizz
i love heart
no offense swedish candy love hearts
yeah one two three oh yeah
these ass
[Music]
iron brothers what is it
iron fruit
iron brew i actually have earrings of
iron brew like little teeny tiny ones i
feel like it's like intrinsically
scottish it's the drink of scotland yeah
this is like what is this rhubarb
i think this is gonna be
it's quite potent
let's do one little crazier and then one
little bit more moderate so that's it
and then just one
little kiss of i'm gonna try this one
that's delicious yeah i mean it's a lot
of sugar
it is quite good yeah all right you
ready
cheers
scotland
i'm gonna go for it i like that i
smelled it like a nice
yeah i think that's a winner
point to scotland point to scotland the
uk one
i'm sorry
hey
hey no yay
you okay
it's a good one yeah you're the best
it's love it's love
the uk might have won but that i will
never forget that salted licorice you
will never forget i will never forget it
you might be able to
keep a little bag if you want
[Music]
oh my god that's disgusting
what is root beer
now i know
[Music]
i mean that tastes really good actually
this is death juice this is essentially
what this is